[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 dans l'actualité de ce
mardi 26 septembre la mobilisation ce
soir devant l'abattoir et guy arrondies
ou dans une nuit debout il ya débuté
comme dans plusieurs autres villes de
france et du monde entier c'est à
l'appel de l'association 269 life
libération animale pour alerter
l'opinion publique sur le sort réservé
aux animaux
nous serons sur place dans un instant
c'était son ultime séance michel loggia
conduit hier son dernier conseil
municipal à montigny le bretonneux tout
récemment désigné sénateurs il doit
quitter ses fauteuils de mer occupé
depuis 2004 et de président de saint
quentin en yvelines quel avenir
désormais pour l'agglomération
elle nous en parlons avec sandrine grand
gang conseillère communautaire
d'opposition première secrétaire du
parti socialiste des yvelines
enfin retour du portrait dans le 7-8
journal nous vous en proposerons un
chaque mardi premier focus ce soir sur
un artisan maître verrier florent
auboise onex il officia bonnel dans la
haute vallée de chevreuse des
rassemblements aux états-unis en
australie mais aussi en france à houdan
dans l'association pardon à 269 life
libération animale organise des nuits de
boue ce soir devant les abattoirs comme
c'est le cas à l'établissement avec dia
rando ou d'en haut nous retrouvons tout
de suite camille lambert bonsoir quelles
sont les revendications de l'association
dans trois catégories alors ce ne sont
pas des revendications à proprement
parler on devrait plutôt parler d'une
sensibilisation d'un principe de cette
nuit debout c'est une veillée nocturne
statique et silencieuse pour
sensibiliser l'opinion publique sur les
conditions d'abattage des animaux
alors pour l'instant une vingtaine de
manifestants fait de militants sont
arrivés il y en aura beaucoup plus dans
les heures à venir et avec moi du coup
le responsable de cette opération dans
les ebooks inédit rachunek soir à l'or
de la descente le pli de conscience du
public quel est l'objectif vraiment de
se rassembler
le blick cependant d'ajustement de
s'habiller est vraiment à un moment de
rendre vraiment hommage 2002
ce
nous utiliserons c'est pour ça qu'il est
vraiment un luxe en a beaucoup c'est
très déplacé à travers le monde
international aujourd'hui même ça va
être de 17 jusqu'à 5 heures du matin
alors pas d'action directe
est-ce que vous avez dire vous avez
parlé de spécisme justement votre
association et antispécistes vous à
terme ce que vous souhaitez c'est la
fermeture des abattoirs
carrément nous ce qu'on souhaite pendant
ces semaines plus sa place également
l'abolition de l'exploitation de
comprendre que justement on s'attaque
pas justement perso dans les dalles à
thouarcé vraiment s'attaque pas aux
employés
quoi que ce soit on s'attaque vraiment
le système spéciste devient species
économique mais que pour nous qui génère
des milliards à travers le monde sur des
êtres sensibles qui pour juste sont
totalement égaux nous tout est dit cela
chaque bit
il n'y a pas il n'y a pas d'espèces ont
mis alors qui dit fermeture des
abattoirs quand même chômage un perte
d'emploi forcément ici à houdan près de
100 personnes travaillent ici dans cet
abattoir juste derrière nous il s'agit
du dernier abattoir porcin de france
hors du coup quel avenir pour ces
salariés quel avenir cette filière et
plus largement pour les éleveurs la
question
de la cause animale est vraiment pu même
être purement politique
justement après faut vraiment moscou rus
justement c'est que là l'opinion
vraiment public se rende compte de tout
ce qui se passe dans ces endroits
sordides parce qu'on parle quand même de
milliards d'êtres sensible vraiment à
travers le monde qui perdent la vie dans
ces endroits sordides qui sont ramenés
dans des conditions horribles qui sont
entretenus dans des conditions horribles
et qui attendent leur mort et puis au
final pour obtenir quoi bas dans des
barquettes et être des êtres et être
vendus donc quand même on parle quand
même d'une situation où vraiment c'est
pas vraiment laid c'est pas du tout
comme vétéran les éleveurs pour nadal
c'est vraiment le système après il ya
beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui on en parle
très peu dans le dans le monde est il
des zombies monde qui travaillent dans
des amateurs qui se sont reconvertis qui
mêle mon ordi très surprenant c'est pour
ça qu'ils sont reconvertis qui justement
à travers des chaînes youtube à travers
des parties montrent que voilà il
possible justement de se reconvertir et
l'otan aussi faire autre chose merci en
tout cas qui n'est dit rachid pour toute
information ce rassemblement se
poursuivre jusqu'à demain même jusqu'à 5
heures du matin et selon l'association
du break your centaines d'années sort
merci camilla nicolas kirilow beats aux
moyens techniques l'actualité locale
marquée aussi par les conséquences des
élections sénatoriales nouveaux
parlementaires michel laugier présidé
hier soir son dernier conseil municipal
a monté à montigny le bretonneux
il va tout prochainement démissionné de
ses postes de maire de la ville et de
président de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
contraint par la loi sur le non-cumul
des mandats séance forcément
particulière hier après 13 ans à la tête
de sa commune nicolas kirillovitch
étaient sur place
un hommage et de l'émotion sur le visage
de michel laugier le tout nouvel élu du
sénat faisait ses premiers adieux au
conseil municipal une instance dans
laquelle il siège depuis 16 ans
successivement directeur de cabinet de
nicolas à bout pendant trois ans et
depuis 2004 maire de montigny le
bretonneux galice est un mélange
de fierté de bonheur et de tristesse
aussi parce que j'ai là un petit peu dit
si pâle qui est dynamique qui a toujours
été à mes côtés qui se bat à mes côtés
pour défendre montini pour faire évoluer
cette ville et je regrette vraiment je
regrette vraiment cette loi sur le
non-cumul le président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines a désormais un mois pour
démissionner de ses différents mandats
locaux
son départ au sénat grâce à la large
victoire de la droite dans les yvelines
marque un tournant pour la commune de
montigny le bretonneux dans le livre de
montigny leur a écrit n'y ait un
chapitre important c'est une page qui se
tourne et avec un petit peu de et
beaucoup même d'émotions pour le mérite
bia il a fait
bien évidemment montini un superbe
travail a beau travail à l'agglo
également et puis là maintenant je suis
sûr qu'il fera beau travail et si de son
côté l'opposition a salué aussi
l'élection de son meilleur adversaire
même si leur relation se sont révélés
souvent tendues avec la gauche locale
ça a été un élu local de proximité faut
le reconnaître quelqu'un qui a été très
très connue peut être aimé par un
certain nombre d désigné montant ça il
faut tout à fait le reconnaître
maintenant il a glissé le mot dans son
dans son discours final c'est quelqu'un
qui faisait une carrière c'est quelqu'un
qui a fait une carrière politique il l'a
dit qui va poursuivre sa carrière
politique maintenant au niveau national
les premiers pas de michel logis au
sénat sont prévues le 2 octobre prochain
les parlementaires seront réunis pour
l'élection du président de la chambre un
poste clé qui devrait revenir une
nouvelle fois livre linois gérard
larcher et michel auger a connu une
ascension politique depuis son élection
à la tête de la mairie de montigny le
bretonneux en 2004 est le nouveau
sénateur a gravi tous les échelons des
mandats locaux
retour sur son parcours avec nicolas
kirillovitch a obtenu le seul michel
laugier 33 voix les images ont presque
13 ans jour pour jour ce 11 octobre 2004
à michel laugier voit son parcours
politique
concrètement débuté il devient alors le
maire de montigny le bretonneux à l'âge
de 46 ans
ému et tendrement ému parce que toute la
soirée j'ai pensé un homme j'ai pensé à
nicolas bour celui que je viens de
remplacer lui qui a siégé à la tête de
ce conseil municipal pendant 27 ans et
demi d'un côté ça fait un drôle d'effet
de se retrouver dans son fauteuil en
fauteuil de maire que le journaliste de
formation aura donc occupé pendant
treize ans et qu'il l'aura vu
progressivement grandir dans la cour
politique yvelinoise réélu maire en 2008
et 2014
michel laugier devient la même année
président de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines sentiment de fierté
sont ils ont aussi de vivre une étape
importante puisque c'est historique que
président de droite préside aux
destinées aujourd'hui de la communauté
d'agglomération et son histoire
politique michel laugier continue de
l'écrire en 2015 candidat de la droite
pour les élections départementale sur le
canton de montigny le bretonneux il
réussir à conquérir un territoire
réservé à la gauche depuis 1994
lorsqu'on gagne un canton pour
lesquelles on est challenger et sa psp
plaisir en plus le gagner d'une si belle
façon je crois qu'il est grand de
satisfaction élu sénateur michel logis
et siégera désormais dans une chambre
connu pour être plus ouverte au
compromis politique
une caractéristique qui devrait lui
correspondre lui le parlementaire de
droite qui n'a jamais été encarté niais
l'ump ni aux républicains on accueille
sur ce plateau sandrine grand grande bon
soir vous êtes conseiller régional
première secrétaire fédérale du parti
socialiste des yvelines nous allons
parler dans un instant avec vous des
résultats des sénatoriales pour votre
parti dans le département et aussi de
l'avenir du ps dans les yvelines vous
est également conseillère municipale à
trappes et conseillère communautaire
d'opposition à saint quentin en yvelines
du coup le futur de l'agglomération vous
concerne directement et michèle losier
va tout prochainement démissionner de sa
présidence un conseil communautaire
extraordinaire doit se tenir dans le
mois pour désigner
son successeur est ce que vous voyez
d'un bon oeil cette nouvelle direction
prochaine où il ya la tête de
l'agglomération
ça peut être une belle opportunité comme
ça peut être absolument dramatique pour
le territoire en fonction de vers quoi
on va s'orienter j'ai cru comprendre
qu'on devrait voter le 19 octobre
donc d'ici là j'espère qu'il y aura
aussi des mains tendues parce qu'on est
une des rares agglomération ou quatre
villes sont mis sur le banc depuis le
départ alors michel laugier cherhal
félicité impose de nouvelles élections
et c'est qu'il a quand même essuyé les
plâtres de cette nouvelle agglo et elle
avait approuvé la gauche ans
oui mais sauf qu'elle soit qu'elles
soient gauchers c'est pour ça qu'elles
sont ni sur le banc mais en tout cas il
a essuyé les plâtres de cette nouvelle
intercos était pas simple mais si on a
quand même beaucoup patiné ça a été ça
n'a pas été simple
depuis depuis janvier 2016 house assez
mis en place à 12
donc maintenant il faut vraiment que
pour l'avenir du territoire qu'on passe
à une vitesse supérieure et qu'on soit
sur une vraie gouvernance partagée donc
en fonction des choix qui avec qui
reviennent aussi à la majorité parce
qu'il me fait majoritaire dans
l'assemblée de l'agglo en fonction des
choix ça peut oui est une belle
opportunité de repartir dans une belle
dynamique comme ça peut être quelque
chose assez tragique alors justement de
mon circulent en particulier pour
succéder à michel laugier les noms des
deux premiers disques président de
l'agglomération joséphine coleman ce
berger la mère de plaisir et et jean
michel fourgous maire d'elancourt est ce
que dans l'opposition vous avez des
préférences peut-être un profil avec
lequel vous préférez travailler
normalement les intercommunalités ya
jeudi un fait majorité infime minorité
on en est là sur une coopération commune
donc on n'est pas sûr normalement une
malle une opposition qui viendraient
systématiquement contre ce qui est
décidé par une majorité ce n'est pas en
tout cas dans cet état d'esprit que
l'intercommunalité doit se construire
c'est un petit peu ce qui a été le cas
ces derniers temps
nous on espère qu'il y aura d'autres
signes et évidemment en fonction du
candidat puisque cissé les parmi les
deux que vous avez cités
des noms qui circulent en voilà je pense
que je pense que nous on aura on aura
une opinion d'en discuter avec
l'ensemble des délégués de gauche mais
on verra quelle sera notre
positionnement mais mais je pense que se
donne pas le même profil après sur sur
ce que sera le territoire en fonction de
qui sera choisi michel auger qui est
l'un des six sénateur des yvelines
désigné dimanche parmi eux aucun élu de
la gauche qui détenait pourtant deux
sièges au sénat
quatre listes était candidate pour le
scrutin division responsable de l'échec
de la gauche selon la sénatrice sortante
du parti socialiste catherine tasca et
qu'il ne briguerait pas de nouveau
mandat
c'est certain que la multiplication des
listes c'est vrai d'ailleurs dans
beaucoup de départements a été mortel il
ya notamment à gauche réflexe suicidaire
puisque toutes les formations concernées
se sont trouvés dans l'incapacité de
négocier des accords vous savez moi en
j'ai fait ma liste avec l'ensemble des
formations de gauche et le résultat
était là ces quatre listes ont été
mortels pour la gauche d'après catherine
tasca
sandrine grand groupe vous conduisiez
vous la liste socialiste est ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ce constat a déjà il
ya pas qu'à christian navet 3 puisque
finale
le parti communiste français avait
décidé de retirer sa liste mais il se
trouve qu'on avait un socle de départ
qui est très basse que catherine tasca
fait référence à 2011 j'aurai bien aimé
est dans la situation 2011 dira qu' il
faut rappeler à ceux qui nous écoutent
qu'en fait c'est une élection où ce sont
les résultats des élections antérieures
qui compte puisque c'est des élections
municipales notamment de 2014 et le
résultat très très faible et les chais
qui a été le nôtre en 2014 qui explique
aussi ce qu'on en soit aujourd'hui avec
un socle de gauche qui était très faible
dans ces conditions là même trois listes
à gauche c'est effectivement mortifère
cirque eux on paye cash
une division quand le socle est très
faible et après la difficulté vous
comprenez bien que on sait compter tout
le monde sait compter qu'on avait bien
anticipé que sur les deux sièges qui
étaient qui avaient été gagnées par la
gauche même s'il y en a un qui ensuite
oublier un petit peu ce d'où ils
venaient mais
on savait bien qu'il ya potentiellement
un siège qui pouvait être gagnée à
négocier avec les partenaires quand vous
savez qu'il ya qu un siège déjà pas très
simple et on a réussi à le faire sur les
législatives et on n'a pas réussi à le
faire sur les sénatoriales et c'est vrai
que c'est dommage puisque avec le
système à plus forte moyenne
il nous manquait 75 sièges 70 sièges 70
voix pardon pour pour obtenir le siège
même parti social s'est classé troisième
de ces sénatoriales dans les yvelines
dernière question puisque le temps s'est
déjà écoulée il ya plus de députés
socialistes du département ni de
sénateurs socialistes aucun aussi
conseillers départementaux est ce que
c'est une véritable crise pour pour le
parti c'est une crise pour la gauche en
général pour le parti socialiste aussi
un on est dans un département de droite
ça c'est un scoop ça on le sait depuis
longtemps c'est pas simple pour eux mais
en même temps il ya un vrai électorat de
gauche qui doit être présenté et donc il
faut que les structures politiques
soient à la hauteur aussi deux de ses
électeurs qui ont envie que leurs voix
soient portées donc on va essayer de le
faire différemment il ya un certain
nombre de territoires de gauche encore
dans les yvelines et puis on appelle
tous ceux qui ont envie de participer à
la reconstruction de la gauche que ce
soit dans les parties où reparti à se
structurer à se mobiliser et nous on
sera là aussi pour les accompagner merci
sans votre grand gang conseillère
régionale ps première secrétaire
fédérale du parti socialiste des
yvelines vous êtes également je le
rappelle conseillère communautaire
d'opposition à saint quentin en yvelines
suite de notre dossier sur le logement
étudiant sa recherche peut parfois être
un vrai parcours du combattant en 2015
selon une étude du nid place 22 % des
jeunes français estimait à cette
démarche difficile à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pôle
universitaire l'agglomération a choisi
de mettre en oeuvre des dispositifs dead
et nicolas landry et camille lambert
entre l'école d'audiovisuel 3 i/s celles
d'ingénieurs l'estaca ou l'université de
versailles saint quentin
quinze mille étudiants se rendent chaque
jour à saint quentin en yvelines pour
faciliter leur installation sur le
territoire la communauté d'agglomération
a doublé son offre de logements en
l'espace de quelques années on avait
peu près 1000 logements étudiants alors
qu'on est un pôle universitaire
important donc depuis ces trois
dernières années l'agglomération à
renforcer son offre et on a plus que
doublé l'offre de logements étudiants
puisque on a plus de 2500 logements
étudiants jeunes aujourd'hui saint
quentin en yvelines compte 14 résidences
étudiantes
la dernière en date inaugurée l'an
dernier la résidence andré dunoyer de
segonzac à guyancourt 147 studio situé
juste à côté de lui vs qu avec des
loyers compris entre 395 et 455 euros et
un engagement porté sur l'environnement
c'est un peu un projet un peu innovant
effectivement aujourd'hui les questions
énergétiques sont un enjeu majeur
une attention particulière est apportée
à l usage dans le logement pour que les
étudiants soient vigilants et permettre
de faire de cette résidence une
résidence passive
donc il produit plutôt de l'énergie
qu'elle en consomme parmi les deux mille
deux cent cinquante logements du
territoire saint quentin en yvelines en
attribue près de six ans pour en
bénéficier l'étudiant doit remplir une
fiche administratives auprès de la
direction de l'habitat
exactement comme un bailleur social
pourrait recevoir des demandes de
candidature là la direction invite à
traite des demandes de logement étudiant
et en fonction des demandes qu'elle
reçoit
c'est une de ses missions ses de
positionner les candidats de positionner
de proposer des candidats aux
gestionnaires des résidences étudiantes
la direction de l'habitat se fait donc
le lien entre étudiants et gestionnaires
mais aussi avec les propriétaires lancé
depuis 2015 le site ce qui le cas vise
regroupe des annonces de particuliers
pour des locations chambres ou studios
en lien avec le blues et avec
l'université avec aussi des associations
partenaires au niveau en matière de
logement des jeunes sur le territoire
donc c'est une réflexion partagée et
ensuite c'est un site gratuit qui est
proposé aux propriétaires et aux
étudiants en recherche de logement
différents dispositifs qui permettront
peut-être aux étudiants de quitter le
domicile familial
selon une étude unis placent publié en
2015 près de la moitié d'entre eux
vivent encore chez leurs parents
elle s'est tenue la semaine dernière la
semaine européenne de la mobilité
et avait pour but de nous faire
réfléchir sur nos habitudes en termes de
transport comment se déplacer demain
c'est l'une des réflexions justement de
la communauté d'agglomération
rambouillet territoire bonsoir thomas
gourland osaka le premier vice-président
de rambouillet territoire avec des
délégations sur la finance et la
prospective territoriale alors vous
organisé ce samedi le rendez vous de la
mobilité ça se passe à partir de 14
heures et jusqu'à 17 heures 30 dans le
parc du château de rambouillet c'est un
vrai un événement festif sur la mobilité
pourquoi le proposer au grand public
et bien parce que c'est d'abord une
compétence très importante de la
communauté d'agglomération d'assurer la
mobilité sur notre sud yvelines et je
salue à ce sujet mon collègue daniel
montent en charge le transport mobilité
à l'agglomération et le président bien
sûr nous avons souhaité faire cette
grande manifestation afin de
premièrement marquer le coup c'est à
dire montrer nos habitants que nous
saisissons au sujet que nous l'abordons
avec les spécificités de notre
territoire et on en parlera peut-être
après mais c'est aussi l'occasion de
lancer ce fameux projet tornado qui nous
occupe depuis un certain nombre de mois
maintenant voir d'année justement ça
sera la vitrine de cette journée le
projet tornado qui est lancée par
rambouillet territoire c'est un projet
retenu par l'état lancement officiel ce
samedi en quoi consiste-t-il
concrètement alors c'est un projet qui
nous a qui nous a occupés depuis
maintenant quatre ans parce que on avait
constaté que bien sûr même s'il
transporte est une demande très forte de
notre territoire nous avions une
spécificité rurale qui faisaient que
nous pouvions pas proposer en solutions
de ses demandes à transport classique et
donc il fallait qu'on trouve de
nouvelles solutions il s'avérait que sur
l'offre du marché mais il y en avait pas
et au lieu d'attendre que les choses
arrivent aussi dix mois saisir ce sujet
et on va engager avec des partenaires
nouveau mis autour de la table une
démarche de réflexion sur le véhicule
autonome sur notre territoire et ans
l'ado pour la petite histoire pour ceux
qui sont de ma génération les plus
chanceux ne connaîtront pas mais c'est
le cheval de zorro et c'était
l'opportunité de pouvoir le sifflet
qu'il arrive et le projet tornado à long
terme c'est qu'on puisse offrir sur
notre territoire un véhicule qui viendra
nous chercher à l'endroit nous sommes de
manière autonome électrique très propre
et nous emmener un autre endroit du
territoire
et puis ensuite
on poursuivre nous occupation et le
véhicule est allé chercher quelqu'un
d'autre alors ce projet tornado va
rentrer dans une phase d'expérimentation
est rentré même dans une phase
d'expérimentation un test d'un véhicule
autonome sur une durée de trois ans
c'est ça c'est ça exactement notre
partenaire nos partenaires nous avons
plus d'une quinzaine de partenaires
autour de la table mais piloter et
principalement par renault constructeur
bien connu va mener sur trois ans un
certain nombre d'expérimentations
techniques pour arriver à terme sur la
troisième année à pouvoir offrir à nos
habitants l'expérimentation d'un
véhicule complètement autonome qui
roulent sans conducteur et donc pour
cela bien on va travailler itérative
mans et on a créé aussi le laboratoire
de la mobilité mais on en parlera qui
permettra aux industriels de définir des
zones à mon très en amont les réels
besoins du territoire alors 2 pour cette
phase de test cela le véhicule autonome
et testé sur un parking c'est sa version
commerciale nous avons aussi
d'expérimentation le partenaire
carrefour de rambouillet nous a permis
de nous installer sur son parking
on fait ainsi reculé navette au dos d'un
petit bus d'un point à l'autre du
parking et permettra à notre partenaire
de tester en situation réelle le
véhicule et nous aux habitants de venir
essayer ce véhicule derrière choisi nous
reste 30 secondes sur quoi cette
expérimentation pourrait déboucher si
c'est concluant dans trois ans
concrètement sur quoi ça débouchera on
peut tout à fait envisager qu'une fois
que l'expérimentation est concluante on
puisse la déployer répondra aux enjeux
que j'ai nommé tout à l'heure et donc
pour ce cet événement il ya une
programmation riche
plusieurs tests là aussi les rosalies
exactement du fils heureuse anciens
voitures anciennes et on aura bien sûr
la démonstration d'une vraie navette
autonome grâce à notre partenaire
transdev et j'avais tout le monde à
venir essayer pour la première fois ce
genre de véhicule un élément qui sera
gratuit gratuit ouvert à toutes les
familles bien sûr tout ça et bien sûr
porté par l'agglo et nos partenaires et
le rendez-vous de la mobilité c'est ce
samedi de 14h à 17h30 dans le parc du
château de rambouillet merci à thomas
gaulin d'avoir l'énergie à l'eau premier
vice-président de la communauté
d'agglomération à rambouillet territoire
plus d'infos sur l'événement sur le site
internet qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
ce sera désormais notre rendez vous
hebdomadaire chaque mardi
vous proposons un portrait sur des
personnes qui font le département des
yvelines et direction bonnel ce soir
dans la haute vallée de chevreuse
pour notre premier focus mathilde et
demi nous fait découvrir
florent boissonnet artisans maîtres
verriers façonner le sable avec ses
doigts pour en faire du verre c'est ce
qu'il fait depuis 15 ans une passion
pour le verre fusionné qu'il en a fait
son métier
le verre fusionné par clean me
permettait de travailler le relief des
verts et que j'avais envie non seulement
de travailler sur le mouvement de la
lumière par rapport aux vitraux est ce
que j'avais envie également c'était que
le mouvement des spectateurs lui-même
influe sur la vision qui va avoir du
travail
une vision qui s'arrondit avec les
formes de ces oeuvres puisqu'elle
représente pour la plupart des ronds
comme des ondes de ricocher dans l'eau
j'essaie de donner un sens à mon travail
par uniquement de décoration et je
travaille sur les forces fondamentales
de la nature et ce lien qu'on a
intimement avec ses forces fondamentales
puisqu'elle constitue notre corps
physique et ensuite formellement c'est
aussi intéressant parce que c'est une
forme stable et que dans mes pièces
j'essaie de
d'avoir des pièces qui sont plutôt
apaisante stable que des choses qui vont
être en déséquilibre combler ouverture
avec la profondeur la transparence et la
couleur une idée qu'il met en lumière en
créant des vérandas des fenêtres mais
aussi du mobilier comme des tables ou
encore des assiettes je vais plutôt
utilisé des couleurs qui vont être plus
contrastée avec des couleurs qui sont
moins dans la nature comme le bleu des
bleus foncés le rouge qui en plus la
caractéristique de très bien fonctionner
en trail mais je vais de quelques fois
aussi avoir du jaune qui se retrouve
moins dans la nature
il ya une spécificité du travail du
verre c'est qu'on travaille la
transparence et il ya des choses bien
particulière qui vont se passer par
rapport à un travail surtout sur des
couleurs opaque par exemple un art qui
est très demandé par les architectes et
les designers mais aussi par des
particuliers qui viennent avec leur
projet pour faire rentrer la lumière au
coeur de la maison on se quitte avec ses
images de l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines elle proposait le
week-end dernier l'opération sentez vous
sport en partenariat avec la région
initiative nationale portée par le
comité national olympique et sportif
français le but encourager la pratique
d'une activité physique et sensibiliser
sur ses bienfaits
animations et conférences étaient au
programme de ce rendez-vous propos
recueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude
l'objectif c'est de promouvoir le sport
soit en pratique libre vraiment on
trouvera une activité sportive physique
régulière mais profitez aussi qu'on soit
au mois de septembre et donc les clubs
accueillent encore tout le public tous
les saint quentinois tous les événements
tous les franciliens dans les
différentes associations donc n'hésitez
pas à vous renseigner pour aller faire
de l'activité sportive régulière dans un
club près de chez vous
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal
reportages et replay a consultés sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile tv et 78 excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]